E aí
[Música]
e como sobreviver no futuro de máquinas
cada vez mais inteligentes
e isso me é o melhor momento é o início
da melhor era da humanidade ou será que
o início do nosso fim essas perguntas
são extremamente pertinentes o nosso
cérebro eu não sei se vocês sabem disso
mas ele faz três coisas ele busca trazer
economia eliminador busca eliminar a dor
aumentar o prazer economizar energia
para a gente sobreviver ele tem feito
isso desde o início da história da
humanidade e a gente chegou até aqui
porque o nosso cérebro Conseguiu dar
conta de ter sem quitação de saber como
vai ser o futuro e se preparar e se
adaptar para ele será que daqui para
frente a gente vai continuar existindo
continuar prosperando continuar tendo
resultado os bons para humanidade é a
primeira vez na história da humanidade
que a gente tem seres inteligentes no
planeta que são mais inteligentes do que
a gente
Quem nunca passou por isso e Nós criamos
esses seres só para dar um exemplo pra
vocês a o alfa Gol Zero é um programa
computacional uma inteligência
artificial que 70 horas jogando
aprendendo do zero não Aprendendo com
humano aprendendo zero ela ganha do não
do humano ela ganha do do sistema que
ganhou do campeão humano anos atrás
então em 70 horas de jogo atinge um
nível sobre-humano aprendendo sozinha
então um período de vida que a gente for
olhar do ser humano e no período de vida
da inteligência artificial no nível que
ela tá hoje a Humanidade para chegar
aqui Demorou mais de 300 mil anos
evoluindo para gente atingir o grau de
inteligência que a gente tem
e a inteligência artificial nesse nível
que acabei de falar para vocês agora que
em algumas coisas é muito melhor do que
os seres humanos Demorou apenas a 60
anos gente durante o tempo de vida de um
ser humano a inteligência artificial
atingiu o nível de inteligência de todas
as nossas outras evoluções ou seja cinco
mil vezes mais rápido que que vai
acontecer nos próximos 50 nos próximos
50 anos a gente deve chegar na super
inteligência que é o que a gente chama
de singularidade que quando a
inteligência das máquinas ultrapassa
inteligência humana nos anos 60 do
século passado o matemático chamado even
good ele falava que ai superinteligência
uso inteligência ia ser a última
invenção da humanidade por quê Porque
quando você inventar uma máquina que é
mais inteligente que o homem ela inventa
uma outra máquina que é mais inteligente
que é mais inteligente e a gente tem uma
explosão de inteligência Esse é o
cenário que a gente tá indo
e como que a gente faz para sobreviver
até lá a gente for olhar esse caminho
para superinteligência falta 50 anos
então a gente e 150 você 50 40 e 60 o
que vai acontecer nas próximas décadas é
que a gente vai alcançar
superinteligência Então como garantir
Qual é a grande questão que eu comecei e
que o nosso cérebro fica inquieto todos
nós ficamos inquietos como garantir que
a gente vai continuar existindo e sendo
relevante com as máquinas super
inteligentes céu são mais inteligentes
do que a gente como é que a gente faz
então a única forma que eu imagino que
esse seja possível não sou eu mas um
monte de outros pesquisadores é a gente
se misturar com as máquinas a gente
quando chegar no nível da
superinteligência o gente se misturou
com elas ou a gente não é mais velho
antes a gente não tá mais aqui então
para que a gente consiga chegar lá a
gente precisa de algumas habilidades que
são diferentes das habilidades que a
gente focava Até recentemente
E se a gente fizer isso certo essa
mistura de humanos com máquina leva a
gente funcionário que é o chamado super
Smart ou sociedade 5.0 que provavelmente
vocês já devem ter ouvido falar a tudo
Essas tecnologias exponenciais que a
gente tá vendo pavimentar o nosso
caminho elas podem nos levar para esse
cenário super Smart ou se a gente quiser
errado ela pode comprometer a nossa
resistência Ok Então como que a gente
chegar lá tem muitas habilidades um dos
temas mais em voga hoje estão as
habilidades do Futuro Quais são suas
habilidades são várias todas elas são
ligadas consórcios quilos mas tem três
habilidades três que resumem todas as
outras três habilidades que vocês
dominarem vocês vão chegar nesse futuro
melhor capacitados e toda a humanidade
focar nessas três habilidades a gente tá
bem nascida a gente tem assim uma
probabilidade muito grande de tem frutos
é super Smart qual é a primeira
e habilidades é habilidade que nos dá a
direção que o pensamento crítico gente o
pensamento crítico é essencial para você
enxergar o caminho qual é o grande
problema a gente tem que ser educado
para ter pensamento crítico a gente não
nasce com ele é diferente da
Inteligência a inteligência ela vem na
sua biologia o pensamento crítico Se
você não for educado para isso você não
adquire qual é o grande problema no
mundo inteiro a educação não é focada no
pensamento crítico da trabalho são
pessoas né que realmente que são pensar
E é disso que a gente precisa a outra
questão é o pensamento crítico que é tão
importante para a gente quanto mais
complexo o mundo fica mais importante a
pensamento crítico porque mais difícil
fica enxergar ele está diminuindo e veja
aumentar a gente dizer que aumentasse o
pensamento crítico Por que que a gente
tem polarização porque não tem
pensamento crítico as pessoas por quê
que tem fake News não tem pensamento
Há muitos dos problemas que nós estamos
vivendo hoje a gente tá começando essa
jornada para superinteligência é
decorrente de falta de pensamento
crítico e aí que que a gente tá falando
né Uma das coisas que fazem o pensamento
crítico faz o período crítico diminuir a
fragmentação de informação eu imagino
que várias de vocês aqui trabalhem com o
marketing de conteúdo em alguma forma só
estrategistas de negócio certo que que a
gente faz o conteúdo de tudo fragmentado
no monte de mídia e a gente procura
fazer o conteúdo mais fácil de ser
entendido que ninguém fica pensar para
que a pessoa clica no seu rapidamente e
seja conduzida para aquele caminho a
gente só recebe conteúdo que não se a
pensar ninguém mais tem tempo para
pensar vontade de pensar e ficar cansado
de pensar Então se vocês se fizerem o
favor de treinar o pensamento crítico e
treinar seus filhos a gente deu um passo
gigante na história da humanidade que
essa coisa que tá mais em falta Olha
como compensa mais crítico é
é mas é necessário primeiro para você
ter pensamento crítico tem que ter
ceticismo um cara cético não é uma
pessoa chata não fofos o cara cético é
uma pessoa essencial nesse cenário ele
tá querendo entender Qual é a fonte de
onde veio isso quem foi que falou como
essa pesquisa foi feita Será que tem
outra opção futurismo faz isso o tempo
todo né a gente fica pensando em vários
cenários em função de determinado fato
então ceticismo amável tá ninguém
brigando com ninguém a gente só tem
grito a gente não tem diálogo então
ceticismo bom é aquele que tem conflito
e não confronto aquele que a gente
entretém um papo com quem é diferente da
gente segue um cara diferente do Twitter
você desconta tudo dele segue ele no
Instagram é aí que você vai me pretendo
essas ideias para ter pensamento crítico
a segunda coisa a gente tem um monte de
viés cognitivo se você é humano Todos
nós temos vieses cognitivos
é um deles eu vi essa confirmação que
que acontece com viés da confirmação não
importa quanta informação tenha no mundo
o seu cérebro vai selecionando só
aquelas que confirmam aquilo que você
quer confirmar Então você indefeso fofa
eu também tá então o que a gente tá
falando aqui como é que eu me desenv eso
dúvida de você mesmo qual é a primeira
pessoa que a gente tem que duvidar
quando a gente ter pensamento crítico eu
toda hora me questiono Será que eu
entendi direito será que está certo as
pessoas tem um monte de certeza eu não
tenho dúvida né as pessoas são juízes na
internet Então olha só superação dos
vieses cognitivos que tem uma maneira
ótima superar10 cognitivo convive com
pessoas de distintas diferentes como é
grão diferente o viés dela de desenv
essa e o seu viés Envia essa Elas
começam a chegar coisas diferentes Ok a
outra coisa a gente se aprender pode
pensamento crítico lógica argumentação e
retórica a gente só prendeu gramática né
fofo que fica a gente aprender na escola
no mundo inteiro gramática sem -
gramática você não aprendeu lógica como
é que
a coisa não faz sentido que não tá
lógica se você não aprendeu argumentação
como é que você coloca a sua ideia de
maneira adequada isso não aprendeu
retórica idem como é que você entende o
que o outro tá falando então para tem
pensamento crítico a gente precisa
desses instrumentos que a gente não foi
educado a quanto curso que tem que fazer
para poder né capacitado a trazendo
crítico o quarto repertório sem
repertório como é que eu comprar uma
coisa com outra como é que eu analiso as
coisas é preciso repertório e veja como
isso favorece a Inovação como isso
favorece a diversidade tão pensamento
crítico precisa ceticismo superação
tivesse cognitivo lógica argumentação
retórica repertório e valores se não
tiver valores como é que eu analiso se
aquilo faz sentido ou não de acordo com
a minha visão de mundo eu tenho valores
éticos eu vou pensar criticamente eu vou
rejeitar um monte de coisa você não tem
valores éticos e eu vou pensar
criticamente talvez eu quero fazer
atalhos que o que acontece com muita
gente que não tem ética
E então percebo é muita coisa para
aprender só que o pensamento crítico ele
só traz para gente uma dimensão porque a
gente precisa é principal Porque sem ele
a gente não faz nada acerta a gente não
sabe o que fazer a gente está perdido
mas ele só traz visão e direção se você
só tem visão direção ele consegue fazer
nada você vai sofrer da síndrome de
Cassandra Cassandra é uma personagem da
mitologia grega ela enxergava o futuro
mas ela amaldiçoada ela tinha o dom de
ver o futuro mas ela era um maldiçoada
que ninguém acreditava no futuro que ela
ver então eu não conseguia mudar o
futuro eu não consegui agir no futuro
Então qual é as habilidades além do
pensamento crítico que direciona a visão
o que a gente precisa ação a gente
precisa atuar nesse mundo conforme a
gente vê as coisas que você feitas e aí
qual é a habilidade principal
adaptabilidade e adaptabilidade estão
inúmeras outras juntas Então olha só
quando a gente fala de dar publicidade é
agilidade velocidade
a cidade é diferente de velocidade tá
hashtag fica a dica agilidade é quando
você consegue ser flexível para mudar de
posição a pessoa ágil ela consegue né
fazer vários tipos de posições rápido é
diferente de anjo eu posso ser ágil Mas
eu posso ser lenta para fazer aquilo
então a velocidade também é importante
resiliência É difícil fazer isso se
adaptar difícil vai se você não for
resiliência não se adapta então outra
coisa que é essencial no processo
adaptabilidade simbiose tecnológica tem
que abraçar tecnologia não tem outra
escolha como é que a gente se adapta
para o futuro das máquinas super
inteligentes se misturando com elas para
isso a gente precisa se misturar com a
tecnologia então quando a gente fala
disso é experimentação complementação de
habilidades entre máquinas e a gente
usam de habilidades e ampliação a
inteligência artificial entre a gente e
aqui na adaptabilidade também tem duas
coisas colaboração e criatividade
desculpa fofos criativa
a unidade mais importante que o ser
humano tá as máquinas são muito melhores
que a gente na criatividade a gente tem
que trabalhar com elas elas conseguem
conectar muito mais dados muito mais
rapidamente para ter solução se a gente
só vai operar uma máquina adequadamente
com a nossa criatividade a gente amplia
significativamente o ambiente criativo
que a gente tá e colaboração também
colaboração entre humanos colocação com
máquina Então se a gente tiver
pensamento crítico a gente tem visão
adaptabilidade a gente tem ação O que
que tá faltando aí humanidade não
adianta você ter só cérebro a gente
precisa de coração Tanto que uma das
grandes questões a do aula de
inteligência artificial qual é a questão
mais importante Inteligência Artificial
hoje moral e ética de inteligência
artificial para que a gente Garanta que
tenha um futuro um cenário humano onde a
gente se respeite onde agente não
descarte as pessoas que são menos
favorecidas então quando a gente fala
disso ser humano não tivesse uma
que fofos e ser humano deveria ser uma
coisa e nata na gente né só que a gente
tá perdendo a humanidade em quantas
máquinas ficam mais inteligentes nós
estamos ficando o que menos 11 anos
Então olha só o que que torna a gente
humano e diferencia a gente da máquina o
pensamento crítico uma delas as máquinas
vão ter pensamento crítico delas atingir
um nível humano e aí a gente tem emoção
empatia e ética que que tá acontecendo
todo mundo tá sobrecarregado com pressa
não se emociona mais a gente não se
emocionar a gente tá nesteziado a gente
tá anestesia é o oposto de estesia que é
sentir a gente tá nesteziado tem que
sentir se você não sentir você não fica
na memória você não fixa na memória você
não consegue nem tomar decisões corretas
porque não tá aquilo do mindfullness é
isso é você tá naquele lugar que você tá
sentindo aquilo para fazer toda a sua
atenção naquilo que você tá presente
ética porque quieto
a pessoa que tem queda tá bom Por isso
que eu tô falando então emoção tá em
queda se emocione se emociona dança
canta só porque a gente fala tanto de
experiência no Marketing e negócios
porque tem que falta fofo a tecnologia
revela a humanidade faz a diferença é aí
que a gente ganha o jogo da humanidade
usando a tecnologia então emoção ética
sem ética não tem Sobrevivência para a
espécie humana acabou por isso que as
máquinas tem que ser que a gente também
vejam Ascensão da diversidade que a
gente tá vendo lindo a gente tá vindo
cada vez mais forte é essencial a
atenção à diversidade traz inclusive
repertório pensamento crítico né hashtag
fica a dica e empatia empatia o que faz
você sentir o outro dores e Prazeres do
outro quanto mais tela você usa menos
empatia você tem que a da empatia também
ok então tem que resgatar para ser
humano então o que que eu desejo para
vocês que é o mesmo que eu desejo para
mim para os meus filhos para os meus
netos para quem vier nas próximas
gerações
e a gente consiga chegar no futuro
realmente bom para humanidade e que a
gente lá na frente tem um futuro super
Smart pensamento crítico para direcionar
a visão de vocês para ter visão de
futuro várias visões do Futuro a gente
escolher o futuro que a gente quer a
hora que você escolheu o futuro que você
quer Eu quero que você tenha muita
adaptabilidade treina muito para ser
adaptável para que você tem ação e
consiga ser empilhar você atue no mundo
e não esqueça da humanidade que a em
função da sua humanidade da minha da
nossa que a gente vai garantir o futuro
da humanidade como um todo o